welcome to this video I'm playing finger
slip from Denmark yes okay um Italian
game two nights defense I think 95 is an
interesting move freely but I don't
don't know it really too well mmm Bishop
to d6
now you can play that move and in
various positions never saw it here okay
I'm trying to make immediate use all of
this try to attack his night if he takes
rook g1 that's good for white I Bishop
f7 is also good for word
yep possible but I thought g5f it's
played g5 first night c4 I take on one
f6 just just clearly better for white so
this one I have pushed him back here is
there some way to to keep the bishop I
would like to keep it but maybe there is
no way
Knight c3 have just just develop I have
one lots of space with them the Jeep
won't push
I really believe this is a serious way
to play this is not like some wiki movie
for its it's gaining space and helping
me to develop initiative on the kingside
Queen h5 the idea and maybe night f5 if
he goes now 26 schneider five
yes the zone I just spotted this as well
d5 this is sam this is some bit
uncomfortable
hmm okay yeah something went wrong down
maybe it wasn't so good I really think
so I like on move seven white must be
excellent i really believe that this of
course now looks okay Ferb like he's got
the center it's not it's not the lost or
anything but certainly nothing that i
can be particularly thrilled about
so tweenage 5 after all preparing long
castles
I don't think that this is so so bad for
me King can go to c 1 and F for I serve
is something check
you know my king is okay here he doesn't
have any many big threat against it and
I'm going at four
I'm ahead on the clock this is something
to mark in the calendar
96 would win a piece so he probably
needs to react in some way castles long
for instance but this Hank say seven hmm
yeah this basically means that I should
be in good shape should I go over 26
probed earshot night Queen g7 this is
some useful square yeah just covering
that
still Queen g7 looks very nice
okay so I need to how to play that
Knight f3 Hanks Hanks this piece
ok
this shouldn't be too bad
yeah I thought this was good now
I went King we want to prevent the Queen
f4 with the check and the thought Quinn
a fork when g7 should be it should be
very good for me I don't really know
where why he wants to go with the night
now they're still a sem name but he
doesn't really have a night move
rook e8 does queen e 5 this is very
strong this is very strong this kind of
fear but i have now look ahead the Queen
trade also has helped us okay just I can
also take here and he's got one second
on the clock I didn't really look at the
clock okay can take him and they can
take here with check
yeah it all wins check black for jets on
time yeah yeah this was a game of up and
downs I really like the g4 idea but
around here I'm in bad shape that's the
sea played disc plates as well so he
played Knight a5 this may be good and
maybe around here I need to do something
else I think this is really a valid an
interesting way to play but I need to
improve especially the problem was that
he never took here until it was really a
good moment to do so he and night be
three ND force the computer suggestion
yeah something like that it is clear
that here this night eh flawless band
and this is a very very strong move
intending d5 and no I'm struggling
what I actually believe is that here
maybe should cancel but what was a
mistake was this means this is a mistake
and a pretty big one I think it gives me
decent play again if he keeps the
tension I really have a hard time to
decide what to do with my king with the
center it's just not good check and this
was nice because now I have the IDF for
and my king is not a problem especially
this was not helping at all because the
king is better on c1 then on d2 and did
to neglect it therefore I diem and here
or the computer actually gives G success
even better yeah I didn't think about g6
yeah it is a good move it is a good move
attacking ephi from the site very strong
okay this is the the positional way to
play and it's also much better for white
yeah here okay seven is even stronger
but this is very very good as well
alright thanks for watching